[Musik]
sebastian liege stellt streicht sagte
mutter her und demonstriert wie ich will
mutter nach der verdünnung mit joghurt
wasser und pflanzenöl noch übrig bleibt
[Musik]
ein fall für den lebensmittel detektiv
man holt morgens das päckchen aus dem
kühlschrank waren beschmiert sich das
brot und butter aber mutter
[Gelächter]
auffällig das wort butter ist dem
produktnamen nicht enthalten
stattdessen klingende namen wie streich
gut butter rahm und streichen
[Musik]
ist darf man niemand mehr butter genannt
werden sondern nur streich zarte
kreation mit einem hauch von mutter mit
hilfe einer selbst gebauten apparatur
will der produktentwickler zeigen wie
solche straftaten butter alternativen
hergestellt werden
[Applaus]
fertig ist unsere mischt reich fed
maschine für den lukrativen butter
genuss lukrativ für die hersteller denn
die sparen an der teuren hauptzutat der
butter sebastian nutzt für seine version
gerade so viel dass der typische
buttergeschmack erhalten bleibt joghurt
dagegen ist recht preiswert gibt eine
schöne frische hat viel wasser joghurt
gibt nicht nur geschmack er sorgt auch
für ordentlich volumen
[Musik]
die butter schon mal richtig schön
aufgeschlagen jetzt puppen wir das ganze
noch mal schön auf mit einem andern
außer butter mehr fett bessere
streichfähigkeit dafür sorgt den lege
smeekes rapsöl das kostet gerade mal ein
fünftel von milchfett doch damit nicht
genug jetzt wird's richtig günstig nicht
aus schluck wasser
echte butter darf höchstens 16 prozent
wasser enthalten
doch bei streichfett kreationen gibt es
keine solchen limits sebastian lee
gezeigt wie viel wasser da reinpasst
[Applaus]
ein emulgator pulver sorgt dafür dass
sich alles verbindet
fertig ist unser volumen wunder worum
mal sehen was ich so aus vier stücken
butter rausgeholt habe mutter darf der
produktentwickler seine kreation jetzt
nicht mehr nennen
formal handelt es sich um ein
sogenanntes misch streichfett aus vier
stücken mutter habe ich jetzt 2467
schalen mit streichfett mit
buttergeschmack gezaubert das nenne ich
mal ne pfiffigen trick der
lebensmittelindustrie wirklich vor allem
mit blick auf die gewinnspanne
denn die streich zarten alternativen
enthalten günstigere zutaten als butter
kosten im geschäft aber fast das gleiche
der preisunterschied beträgt gerade mal
20 cent egal ob bei marke oder no name
produkten
[Musik]
noch dreister langt die industrie bei
den light varianten hin
sie sind nicht nur streichfähig sondern
auch noch kalorienarm während in
herkömmlichen milchprodukten noch rund
60% öle und fette stecken enthalten
light varianten noch weniger von den
teuren zutaten solche produkte bestehen
oft mehr als zur hälfte aus wasser
[Musik]
erkennen kann man das an der hauptzutat
die muss ganz oben stehen hier ist eine
ganzflächige variante wasser als erste
zutat da waren kollege dran der hat
richtig drauf
das ding hat er bestimmte norden bekommt
der brotaufstrich wird zwar mit
buttergeschmack doch drin steckt gar
keine mehr
lediglich pflanzenfett erst das aroma
sorgt für den buttergeschmack für den
verbraucher bedeutet es wenn meine
butter oder meine meine streichfett viel
wasser enthält bezahle ich natürlich für
wasser und nicht für butter wenig
kalorien sparen möchte reicht es in der
regel die butter dünner aus brot zu
streichen aber es muss kein leitprodukt
sein denn das ist in der regel auch
genauso teuer wie butter unserem wunsch
nach streicher butter ist die industrie
nachgekommen
allerdings mit produkten die in vielen
fällen mit butter kaum noch etwas zu tun
haben
für uns eine erleichterung für andere
richtig lukratives geschäft wer nicht
auf die streich zarte variante am morgen
verzichten möchte der schaut am besten
nach wo in der zutatenliste die mutter
auftaucht je weiter vorne desto besser
[Musik]
was kommt bei euch aufs boot
herkömmliche butter streichfett oder
margarine sagt es uns in den kommentaren
und wenn er nochmal über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips